だからそういう働きがとにかくあるんですね
生命には それはこの命という言葉で理解していても構いませんし
生きているという言葉で理解していても構いませんし
で それは命根と書いているところなんですね
命根でしたっけ で そこまでは物質的な窓口
それから心の働きもまた別な窓口
いくつかありますね だから物質的な窓口は五根と
それから眼根 頂根と それで七つ
それから命根と八なんですね
八種類あります 心の窓口はまた残りは千
なんでそういうふうに分けてますかというと
この私たち人間が命だというのは
体持っているものに命だというんですね
例えば科学的には体が持ってないと生命じゃないんですね
例えば一個の細胞の体でも持たないと生命じゃないんだと DNA
はちゃんとできてないと生命じゃない
それでもDNA半分できていたっても生きているものはいるんですね
だからウイルスというのはDNAを半分しか持ってないんですね
半分というかもう片っぽしか持ってない
いわゆるすごい不完全な構成なんですね
それもやっぱり命として
生命として認めざるを得ないんですね
とにかくアミノ酸でできてるんだから
で そこまでですね 科学的な知識ではわかるのは
でも生命にはやっぱり心の働きもあって
体は機械であって その機械を動かしているものとして心は別にあるという
別な働きの流れあるというふうな仏教で思っているんですね
そこで同じ物質はコピーしていっちゃうでしょうし
だから物質は機械だからといってずっと個体としていくわけじゃなくて
細胞っていうのはいつでも死ぬ
死ぬたびに死ぬ前に一つコピーを作っておく
そこでいろいろプログラム次第にこのどれぐらいコピー作るかっていうことも決まってるし
例えば子供の場合はたくさんコピー作っちゃうんですね
そこで成長していっちゃうんですね
体のスケールがどんどん大きくなっていっちゃうんですね
それであるところで そういうふうに大量に作ることはストップして同じ量を作るんですね
それ百個の細胞が死ぬと
その代わりに百個を作っておいておくと
そうすると成長が止まったことになるんですね
それからもう同じ量じゃなくて
もう死ぬ量よりは作る量が少なくなっていっちゃうんですね
それで体はどんどん退化して老化していっちゃいますね
でも 死ぬ時でも 我々は大量の細胞の塊として死んじゃうんですね
死ぬっていうことは 細胞のこの機能は全部停止しちゃうんですね
分裂して新しいコピーを作ろうという働きはそこでストップになってしまっちゃう
そこまで だからそこまでの体なんですけど
実体としての一つの体があったわけじゃないんです
ずっとコピーしっぱなしでの流れですね
物質の流れ で 同じく心という働きがあって
それも流れるんですね
同じ心を二回あるわけじゃないんですね
一つの心をなくなると
すぐ新しい一つのコピーを作っちゃうんですね
寸時に 心の場合は体と違って中大変なんですね
ということは 例えばこの細胞の場合はね
作った細胞も随分似ているんです
小さい時は一つの細胞からちょっと種類違うのはね
細胞を作りますけどね
一旦基本構成できちゃったらそれやめちゃうんですね
やめて似てる 例えば骨の細胞は骨の細胞を作っておく
そういうふうにこの同じ細胞を作り
作っていくんですね 心の場合はそうじゃないんですね
いくらかは決まりはあるんだけど
まあかなりややこしいんですね
例えば怒りの心と欲の心っていうのは正反対なんですね
怒りは物に対して攻撃する
欲は物を自分のものにしようというふうに引っ張る
だから対象を引っ張るか対象を引き離すかという
全く違うんですね だからものすごい喜びがある時は怒れません
正反対だから 喜んで怒ったかっていうことはないんですね
で だから嫉妬する心やらね
まあ怒りの心やら 物惜しみの心やら
それから欲の心っていういろんな心があります
それから善心もあるし
サマーディ作る心と銀行強盗する心っていうのは随分もう違うんです
でも同じ心のコピーの過程で
これどっちでもあり得るんですね
どっちでもあり得るんです
それから 例えば銀行強盗やってる人が後で瞑想してサマーディの心を作ったというと
すぐその場ではできないんですね
やっぱりこの悪い方向へ行った心はじわじわといい方向へ持っていって
それからサマーディの方向へ成長していかなくちゃいけないんです
そういうふうな いくらかの方向性ではね
決まりはありますけどね
でも本当わからないんですね
心の働きというのは 今いい人は明日もいい人ですよということはわかりません
今日怒った人はやっぱり明日も必ず怒りますよということにはならないんですね
わかりません そんなことは
といっても また性格的にやっぱりいくらかこの心っていうのはまあ癖というものあるんだから
だからそこら辺でね 悪いこと考える人はいつでも悪いことばっかり考えるようになってしまうということもあります
曲がっちゃうんですね
方向 いいことを考える人はいい方向へばっかり考えるしというふうに
そういう習慣的な癖もまたあって
で わかりにくいんですね
それから この物質的な働きと違って
心の働き またこの窓口ありまして
一番目はマニンドリアン
マニンドリアンというのは意識そのもののこと
心そのもののこと 生きているものやと
生命といったら そこに心というものがありまして
心で外界 内外を認識する
だから生きているものやというんですね
たとえ一個の細胞のアメーバにしたっても
もう正真正銘の生き物なんですね
なぜ正真正銘の生き物かというと
周りの外界をちゃんと認識しているんですね
細胞一個しかないんだけど
だからこれは食べ物かないかとかね
前に進んでべきか 後ろに進むべきかとか
前後ろさえアメーバにはないんだけどね
まあ私たちから見れば
いくらかそういうふうに考えられますけどね
とにかく周りを全体的に感じして認識している
ですから その認識する働きなんですね
それをマニンドリアン
マナという窓口でやってくれるんですね
問題はそれはどこにあるかって
ことなんですけど やっぱり本当は場所はいらないんですね
物質的な働きじゃないんだから
だから体全体にそれあるんです
心は体全体にあるものであって
ある一箇所にあるものじゃないんです
一箇所にあると思った人々
魂ですよと勘違いしましたし
そう思ったのは やっぱり物質しか人間には理解しにくいんだからね
この瞑想したりして魂があるんだとか言ってる人々も
結局物質しか認識していないんですね
だからある一箇所で何か心というものは機能しているんだという風に考えてしまって
この魂は体の中にどこにあるんです？また探すんですね
で ウパニシャッドではやっぱりそれは心臓の中に入ってるんだと
大きさまで決めている
親指くらいの大きさであるんだと
そこで医学を発展すると
それは脳細胞やと で また勘違いしている
そこで脳の研究していると
どこに自意識があるかというと
ないんですね 脳の各部にはまた仕事を別々やりますからね
自意識はどちらでも作ってないんです
見られるところで見る働きだけしているし
思い出すところではそれしか何もやりませんし
音を聞く聴覚のところではそれしか受け取ってないし
それから体の器官を動かしている部分はまた決まってるんですね
脳の中で全部仕事を別に綺麗に分けてるんですね
窓口いっぱいあるんです
脳細胞の中にも それだったら私がいるんだということはどこにありますかと
どんな脳細胞がそこを作っているかと
仏教を勉強している人々はそういうそういうことがいちいちもう現代人ですけど
なんかまあふざけた科学の知識で
もう科学万能やという感じで
科学っていうのはまだまだもうよちよち歩く状態でもないんだからね
大したことはないし で
それでやっぱりこの煩悩やら自意識やら作る脳の何かどこかあるでしょうと
そこら辺は何かしてくれるならば
まあそれで悟りじゃないかと
それで全ての煩悩から心っていうのは
そういう風に人が言うのは聞いたんだけどね
だからこの連中に科学を教えた先生たちにぶん殴るしか方法ないんですね
やっぱり くっだらないことを言ってる
とにかく明確に脳のことを見ると
脳はどこにでも自意識というものは作る場所がないはずなんですね
そこでまた推測するんですね
脳でもいまだ理解してないところはあるでしょう
いわゆる明確にどんな仕事をしているかわからないところもまだまだあるんですね
脳の研究は全部終わってないんだからね
で なかなか全部できないんですね
いろいろ道徳もそれなりにありますから
研究してくだいたら まあそういう研究者
科学者っていうのはどれほど恐ろしい
汚いことをやるかっていうと
もうキリがないんだからね
平気で患者さんが病院に行ってと思ったら
あんたこういうこういう病気だよで
徹底的にその人の脳細胞を解剖して調べる可能性あります
だからほとんど人間できてないんですね
だから大量殺人する機械までもう平気で作るんだからね
だからもう銀行強盗やる人々っていうのは
そんな大した汚い恐ろしい人間じゃないんですよ
銀行強盗しただけのことだからね
そこでも人類に大変迷惑かけたとかね
そんなことはないし その人捕まっちゃえばそれで問題を解決するしね
だから本当にこの世の中であり得る一番の恐ろしいグループっていうのは科学者なんですね
そこで悪いことを自分たちこそ人類のために頑張っていると
また嘘を言っていることなんですね
人類のためにね 一人も何もやってないんです
ですから このそういうわけはみんな知ってるんだからね
脳の研究っていうのはいろいろコントロールされてありましてね
そうでなければないと
まあよくやるだろうと思いますけど
とにかく今まだまだわかってない部分というのはね
この ありますけどね まあ論理的に言うのは
我々はこの進化の過程で
この動物の次元からどんどん人間になってしまったんですね
人間になってしまったところで
この 脳の一部が成長したんですね
一部は動物にもあるんですね
だけど動物にない一部は人間持ってるんですね
だからキリスト教から言えば
それは神様が人間に作ってくれたものですから
そこら辺は大事に魂になりますけどね
でも科学者から見れば
やっぱり生命として生きていきたいという実感っていうのは動物にもありますから
その原始的な脳にあるだろうと
心理学もそれほど支えているところはあるんですね
だから心理学的に見たっても
人間っていうのはすごい原始的で汚いんですね
決して心の本当の元の状態っていうのは清らかなものじゃないんですね
すごい自己主義で自分のためしか考えませんしね
それでいろんな強引に善悪判断するような
この良心というものは作って育ててあげなくちゃいけない
ですから 脳でもやっぱり人間として発達する前から持っていた脳の方にそこら辺ないかなと
思ってはいるんだけど
それ研究不可能なんですね
人の脳のそれ こういう恐ろしい部分を引き起こしちゃったらね
どうなるかわかりませんしね
それはやってはいけないことだから
人はいきなり動物のようにしてしまうということはね
だから狂ったよりは恐ろしいんだからね
人は狂ったならば それまた正気に戻さなくちゃいけないし
それよりもいかに 持っていってっていうことは
医学の世界でもやっぱり不可能なことになっています
一応今まで発見しているところから言えば
やっぱり脳は各部が自分の別な仕事を持っていますから
いまだに研究してないところをいじってみたっても
自分たちがまた別な仕事を持ってるだろうということは発見するでしょうと思いますね
自害しかどこにあるかということはないんですね
そこで結論として私が言いたいのは
やっぱり細胞一個一個生きてるんだからね
だから心という働きは電気エネルギーみたいに全部同じく働いてます
例えば電気機械を作ったのか
電気は全部の機械を通して行くんですね
あるところに電気がつなげなかったら
その機械は故障なんですね
例えばラジオがあるとする
で ラジオがあるならば
やっぱり電池があって
電池から出てくるエレクトロンという電子がすーっと働いて流れてるんですね
そこである場所によって
この電気の流れはちょっと変わってしまっちゃう
で それによって我々にラジオという機能が生まれてくるんですね
電気は確実にアンテナまで行くんですね
でもアンテナに行く電気とスピーカーに行く電気は随分違うんですね
だからアンテナだったらね
ほんのわずかなこの電子の進路を取って
その進路はまた電気エネルギーを持って
それはどんどん強化して力強くすると
であるレジスタンスから電流が流れると
そこで電気の流れが止まると
あるところへ行ったら止まって
もっとすごいすごい電気を出してくれるとかね
あるところで一定の 周波数で電気をコントロールするとかに
そういう風にいろんな場所で決まってる仕事があるんですが
そのどこにでも電子というものは働かな-- 動かないとラジオは働かないんですね
故障したラジオを修理する人は何を見るかというと
メーターを持ってきて
どこに電気が流れてないかと見るだけ
ここら辺 ここからAからBまでは電気は流れてないんだ
だからこのABの間にあるこの部分が死んでるんだと
それを入れ替えましょうということで修理するんですね
ですから 心はずっと働いていて
目に入ったら違う働き
鼻に入ったら違う働き
耳に入ったらそちらで決まってる働きをしているだけ
でもどこに行ったっても一つの働きをしてる
認識する 認識するっていう働きはするんです
目に入ったら認識する
でも認識するものは違う
耳に入ったら認識するんだけど
音を認識する それで五根に関係ない場合は
頭の中でいろんな概念やらいろんなことを認識する働きをするんですね
だから何も見てない 聞いてない時も人は死んでますか？死んでないんですね
電気エネルギーは他のところに働いています
この電気エネルギーみたいなものなんですね
心っていうのは だから場所はどこっていうことじゃなくて
どこでもあるということにもなる
そこで基本的なそのエネルギーにはマニンドリヤというんですね
認識する働きに マニンドリヤは何根でしたっけ？意根ですね
それからスッカ えっと
ドゥッカ・ソーマナッサ・ドーマナッサ・ウペッカという感覚のいわゆる
スッカ・ドゥッカ・ソーマナッサ・ドーマナッサ・ウペッカ
5つの窓口みたいに決めてるんですね
スッカっていうのは大変楽しいと思う
感じること ドゥッカっていうのは苦しいと感じること
だからスッカっていうのは大変楽しくて楽だという感じること
ドゥッカは苦しいと感じること
ソーマナッサっていうのは軽くは楽しいと感じること
もっと違う言葉で言えば
スッカっていうのはすごい気持ちいいと感じること
ドゥッカっていうのは痛いと苦しいと感じること
ソーマナッサっていうのはもうなんとなく楽しいと
だから柔らかいんですね
気持ちいい 柔らかくて楽しく感じること
ドーマナッサっていうのは
まあ精神的に悲しみを感じることですね
ウペッカっていうのは別にそういうふうに判断できない感覚ですね
で そこでさらに説明すると
スッカはもう体で感じやすい
それで禅定を作ったら心でも感じられます
ドゥッカも体で苦しみを感じやすい
そこは心で感じることもできます
ソーマナッサ・ドーマナッサはあくまでも心だけで
心の楽しみ 心の悲しみですね
ですから もっとわかりやすくするならば
体を通して 耳やら目やら体やら
そういうものを通して楽しみを感じる場合はスッカなんですね
で 心で感じる 心だけで感じる楽しみはソーマナッサなんです
同じく体で感じる目やら耳やら鼻やら口から体から感じる苦しみはドゥッカなんですね
心で感じる悲しみはドーマナッサなんです
そのスッカ・ドゥッカ・ソーマナッサ・ドーマナッサ・ウペッカというこの5つは
また窓口として扱っているんですね
なんでそれが窓口になるかというと
それでそれがあるんだからみんな生きていけるんです
この解脱したくないっていう五蓋
無明 生きていきたいという大変な恐ろしい考え方は
この五つの感覚というか
感受性から生まれるんですね
なんで我々は選んで選んで生きていますかね
食べるものもこれではなくてこれだと選ぶ
着るものもこれではなくてこれですよと選ぶ
それから生きていなくちゃいけないと
なんとかしなくちゃいけないという感じが
そういうソウムナス・ドーマ
ピーティ・ソク・ソウムナス・ドーマナス・ウペッカーと五つから生まれてくるんですね
それから今まで言ったのは
まあ別に善も悪でもない
ただの生命としての働きとしての窓口
生命という区役所の  あの
ただ 国民登録することやら
そんな感じの まあいいか悪く何のことない働きなんですね
それからいい方向の働き
区役所の場合で言えば
まあ道路をいろいろ処理するわ
ゴミを あの 持っていくわとかね
まあそういう人々のために
その住んでいる人々の住民の役に立つこともするんですね
いろいろ文化活動をやっ-やるとかね
区役所そういうこともやってますからね
で この それ次に出てくる窓口は善の方に
生命を上達するために
発達するために 進化するために
あるいは解脱するのに導くために必要な窓口
それから言ってるんです
それはサッダー・サティ・サマーディ
じゃなくてサッダー・ヴィッジェ・サティ・サマーディ・パンニャー
サッダーっていうのは信ですね
心に信が生まれたら ものすごく元気になって行動する
いい方向へ行動します
信というのはやっぱり
この喜びと似ているんですね
まあ自信 確信ですね いくらかこの心の自信
確信 清らかさというもののようなものを生まれるんですね
仏教ではサッダーというのは確信ですからね
それは知識から生まれてくるんですね
だから 特に仏教を勉強させるということは
この知識ですけど 知識を通して自分が知ったことは真理であるということです
確信が生まれてくる 確信というのは喜びとほとんど似ているんですね
で 確信が生まれたらもう間違う方向へは行かない
自分がもう真理を知っているんだから
だから悪いことをしない
その人は 罪も犯さない
その代わりに善行為をするようになってしまう
ですからサッダー 信が大変人々をいい方向へ導く窓口
仕事 働いてくれます 次にサッダー
ヴィリヤ 精進ですね その場合
やっぱりこのままで良くないと
もう立派な人間にならなくちゃいけないんだと
心の汚れをなくさなくちゃいけないという精進の方はヴィリヤと言うんですね
サティは常に自分に気づいている働きですね
サマーディはやっぱり統一していること
その中から喜びが生まれるんです
何かにボーっとやることに注ぐ
存じにボーっとしてそれをやるという場合はかなり苦しみがないんですね
ですから サマーディの癖がついた人にとっては苦しみなく生きていられるんですね
例えば やらなくちゃことはいっぱいあります
ああ言えばああだこと言っている人にとってはサマーディがないんですね
統一性がない それじゃなくて
じゃあまずこれやって
次にこれやって 次にこれやってとかね
きちんと決めて集中して
その都度やることに集中してボーっとしてできるって人は喜びのような感じがあるんですね
生きること苦しくなくなっちゃう
ですから このサッダー
ヴィリヤ サティ サマーディ
五番目パンニャーですね
で パンニャーっていうのは知恵なんですが
それは決して知識ではありません
次にまたアンニャータン・ニャッサーミという心の働きがあります
アンニャータンというのは知らないことをニャッサーミ
知ろうではないかという意味なんですね
道を知ろうという まあなんか好奇心ではないんだけどね
まあそういう窓口もあります
みんなそれまあ一応営業休止です
状態にしていますけど
やっぱりその窓口はね
フルに生かしちゃうと
活動させると必ずしも人間はまあ進んではいきますね
いまだに知らなかったこと
わからなかったことを知ろうではないかという
それやってる窓口も心の中にありますね
で ほとんどの人間の場合はそれは営業停止ですね
まあ言われる通りにそれでいいんじゃないかと
そこは良くないんですけどね
それは随分この互恵で
それ営業停止にしていたんだからね
この日本の経済状態はね
戦線脱出する方法もいまだに見つからないということに
偉そうなことを書いている
この新聞記者やらね 経済的なことを書いている記者たちの記事だから
記事だから堂々と何でも書けますからね
まあ実践するのは難しいんですけどね
だから記事を書く人ぐらいでもね
堂々と答えを書けばいいでしょうし
全然誰も書いてない こうすればいいかということ
だから言ってることはいい加減という感じになってしまうんだから
本当に実行現場で働いている人々の役には立たない
役に立たないんですね
やっぱりこれこそやと答えがというふうに出たら
実行する人々はね やるんです
出てこないんですね やっぱり道を知ろうという機能はやっぱり機能してないんです
物事うまくいくならば儲かります
ただそれだけ待ってるんですね
世界経済状況が良くなるまで待とうと
それで儲かるんだと 誰にでも儲かりますけど
それだったら だから そういう働きが心にありますね
知らないものを知りたいと
なりたくない状況状態になりたいと
ということで仏道修行できるんですね
例えば仏教ではね 智慧のことを数軒行って
智慧って何ですかと もう全くピンとこない
それで方法がありましたら
こうこうすれば智慧が生まれるんだ
だからやってみたいという気持ちが生まれてこなきゃ
その人はやらないんですね
試してみたいよね 次にアンニーンドリアン
アンニーンドリアンというのはその
道なるものを知ろうという気持ちが生まれて
その窓口が働くと それで知る働き
悟りの心ですね この境界内を知ると何で書いてるんでしょうかね
知るということはこの悟るっていうことなんですね
だからあのひらめく瞬間ですね
例えば悟りの世界でなくても
何か知らないことを一生懸命研究したり
勉強したりして あ わかったぞということになってしまいますからね
そういう働きもあります
それから 次は知り終わってる
そこで心の働きまあ知りましたよと
というちゃんと最後にハンコ押しておかないと
ファイルクローズしないとね
何か例えば何とか何とか研究するんだとね
例えば分かりやすく言えば
例えばどこかに殺人が起きて
それで警察は全部この
そういう それは犯罪者をね
調べるための事務所やらね
まあファイルオープンと言うんですけど
英語だったらね そういう働きはもう活動開始するんです
で いろいろ情報探しする
これも知りたい あれも知りたい
それで犯人見つかったらこいつは犯人やと
もう決めることはまあ知ることことなんですね
境界内を知るというこっち書いてるのはね
それはまあ知見ってあった方がいい正しいんだけどね
知る働き それからもうもう見つかったんだからね
それでもう終わったと
ファイルクローズと という風にならなくちゃいけないんですね
もう探すことはないんだと
そういう風にこの窓口みたいな働きは二十二ありますと
この最後に出てきたものは全部人を成長する悟りに導くもの
信からサッダーから始めたものは全部
サッダー ヴィリヤ サティ
サマーディ パンニャー
えーとアナンニャタンニャーヴィーインドリヤ
ニャーティンドリヤ サーニャータッサーヴィーインドリヤッと
アナンニャータンニャッサーミーティンドリヤ
アンニンドリヤ アンニャーティンドリヤ
アンニャーターヴィーインドリヤ
それ全部ギダッスニタンケヤル
心の働き 次にこの 力 なんか科学っぽいですけどね
で 例えばいろいろ あの
例えばテレビに テレビにしちゃうと
あの 映像をする画面があったりして
それから音を出すスピーカーあったりしてとかね
いろいろあの窓口はあるんだけど
それには力が必要なんですね
動かすために ただ 買ったテレビではこのまああのブラウン管はでっかくあるんだけど
そこには行くエネルギーは足らないんだったら映像は映らないんですね
例えばすごい大きな力強いスピーカーがあっても
ほんの僅かしかエネルギーがそこに行かないと音が出てこないんですね
ですから 力っていうのは
そのその窓口にやっぱりきちんとエネルギーを入ってないと機能しないんですね
それでこの根のこと説明して
それから力という項目でまた心の内容を説明しちゃうんですね
ですから この十二根の中で
あの最初は誰にでもありますけど
あのサッダ まあ信と信・正念
それから定と慧とね それから未知のもの
知ろうということと 知るものと
知って終わったというものは
それは全部あればもう悟る可能性はあります
全部揃ってます 窓口は
事務所は でもそこに人がいて働かないと窓口あるだけではね
意味がないんですね ですから
区役所に例えて考えれば同じこと
区役所なんてちゃんと窓口はありますけど
人がいないと そうするともうどうにもならないんですね
だから人がいるっていうことは
そちらでエネルギーがあって
まあちゃんと離婚届やら結婚届はできるんだということなんですね
ですから そういうことでバラという力ということで考えなくちゃいけない
それは九つありますね
この場合もこの三策だから
雑だから あの 善も不善ももう雑にまとめて言ってるんです
どちらでも力が必要ですよと
最初に来るのはあの善の方
いい方向のものなんですね
サッダアヴィリヤ・サティ・サマーディ・パンニャ
それはこの根としても出てきたんですね
信・正念・定・慧は だから信は窓口であって
同時に力にもなる 正念は窓口であって力にもなるということ
一人が二つの仕事をする
念は窓口でもあって力にもなる
定も慧も同じですね それから慚と愧ですね
それも力ですよと それもいいことをする時のエネルギーになるんですね
慚というのは悪いことをするのはもう恥ずかしがる気持ちと同時に
いいことだったらやりましょうというエネルギーになっちゃうんですね
愧は悪いことをするのは怖がるエネルギー
そのエネルギーが働くと
もう働くと働かなく 悪いことできなくなっちゃうんですね
それでいいことをしようという
いいことだったら怖くはない
悪いことだったら怖いという
その怖さが働いてきて
その人を守ってくれるので
ですから慚愧は大変必要な働き
それで逆に無慚愧と無愧もありますね
で 無慚っていうのは恥ずかしくないと
まあ堂々とやるんだという気持ちが出てきたら
もう悪いことをしてしまっちゃう
怖くはないんだと気持ちが出てきたら
まあどんな悪いこともできるようになる
その最後に来る二つは不善行為を行うための働きで
残りの七つは善行為と悟りのためにある働きで
前の五つは悟りのために必要である
次の六と七は善行為すべてのために必要である
八と七は 八と九は不善行為をするために必要なものなんです
ですから いいことをするとかなり力があるという法則なんですね
例えば五力まとめたらサッダアヴィリヤ・サティ・サマーディ・パンニャという信・正念・正定・慧
それを五力といって その力五つもないとサマーディさえも禅定さえも生まれない